away good evening welcome to the safety
and sports ground subcommittee I'm
councel Thomas and the chair of the
committee and to on my left by
councelor basille and councelor Holden
um members of legal environmental and
Regulatory and uh steam guest from
United in Lancashire uh we'll get under
way with the agenda I'm not aware of any
apologies I'm also unaware of any
questions from members of the public uh
so we'll move straight on to item three
on the agenda which
is annual safety report from Lanas
Cricket
Club um we've all had the report out and
we all looked at it you'd like to
surmise and we'll move on to the
subcommittee report the reason there are
no minutes is be due to the uh length of
time between to we have some here but
we're going to get them brought back to
our a committee at a later date thank
you thank you just do
a try that yeah I I'll just do a quick
um introduction um I became operations
director um last year um and a few uh
notable changes uh over the years um as
you'll seeing we've had a 100 bedroom
extension uh that opened last year Prov
um challenging and demanding for all of
us but I just wanted to say thank you to
colleagues and agencies who assisted in
that process um as well as the varying
events that we had through
2023 uh one of the other additions to
the calendar um since previous years was
the addition of the 100 Bowl competition
um so that has added uh for we call
major events into our calendar um thank
you chair for mentioning about
everyone's had the report so we'd be
happy to feel any questions questions
and hand over to my colleague just to
take us through the pry of the
report yeah hello chair colleagues my
name is Steve Neil I'm the head of
security and safety for lire Cricket um
I'm just going to pick out some
highlights of last season and then happy
to take some questions um first thing is
um to inform um the committee that uh we
have now successfully got our safety
officer two Deputy safety officers and
uh head ed through relevant
qualifications over the past number of
Seasons the Cricket Club has operated
with safety officers who were working
towards their level four
qualification um so we're now happy to
announce that um our safety officer has
achieved his level four qualification
the two Match Day safety officers have
also achieved their level four
qualification and the head stward has
achieved his level three qualification
and I sit above them with a level four
qualification and a level five In Crowd
Safety Management and NEOS General
certificate so the reason for that
update chair is to give uh the committee
some confidence that the Cricket Club
has moved forward significantly with
regards to the training of its safety
management team for match days um to
pick out some other highlights firstly
if we could talk about the concerts that
we had um under my direction a
significant review of some key factors
of the concerts particularly the Ingress
uh model the circulation the egress and
the dispersal there was enhanced
safeguard operation based on previous
matters which I believe the committee
are aware of uh and we also ensured that
we were fully compliant with the license
and conditions that have been set for us
by the council feedback from um the
promoter and also from Key stakeholders
are very positive in terms of how those
concerts went so we're very pleased with
that and the invitations for the 2024
concert subgroups uh that are R by the
the uh cricket Club will be going out
this week so we're well ahead of um
where we want to be in relation to the
planning for the 2024 concerts I'd like
to turn to the events of the 7th of July
um last year uh which is a matter of
record on the council's report um this
was a short notice quarter final um of a
T20 fixture held at the Cricket Club it
was um a notice of one week uh on the
evening of the 7th of July there were
other competing events throughout the
region including horse was and rugby
league and the ashes at heading leag um
we did inquire with our agency provider
if they were able to supply qualified
staff and reassured that they weren't
ultimately the test event of the hotel
itself and the new Hospitality area went
well however the council and their
inspection identified a number of uh
unqualified stewards that were on
positions uh deemed safety critical that
was reported back to the Cricket Club
and we took that up with the relevant
supplier and then instigated new
procedures and they up to the ashes I
think the committee are aware that
there's an emergency safety Advisory
Group held today before the first day of
the ashes um and I think it's fair to
say that it was particularly challenging
time for the Cricket Club in terms of uh
bringing in new processes to ensure that
we were compliant with the um SJ Sports
ground Safety Authority guidance uh
which had come out in June of last
year uh revised processes were put in
place which includes now that we only
request trained staff from our agency
providers we won't accept um people who
are working towards their
qualification um this will prove
somewhat challenging for the providers
but also for the industry generally
however we're in a position now where we
um we have to be absolutely certain that
when we're putting a steward on a safety
critical position that they are
qualified uh we have a detailed checking
process which has been verified by
colleagues from the council which
involves randing of qualified level two
stward and responding of qualified siia
staff uh there's then uh a very detailed
check-in process with a stand manager
respond checks and then uh head stward
does a quality assurance of those
positions and a form is then brought up
to the the the safety officer in match
control we pleased to report that club
stewards in levels have increased we're
reaching at 90 90 stewards uh number of
Supervisors and we're about to Embark
another seven of our stewards on a level
three supervisors course so that is
going well from that perspective
um just to highlight in terms of Ashes
day one uh the council identified during
their inspection uh a small number of
stewards who were on safety CR positions
who were qualified um I'll not go into
the details of how they arrived most
positions but the council are aware that
it was an isolated incident uh immediate
measures were put in place on day one of
the ashes uh day two of the ashes saw a
no notice inspection by um colleagues
from the council uh which was to their
satisfaction so the measure measures we
put in place had been successful those
measures continue throughout the season
and will continue into this season um
and we're very very confident in terms
of ensuring that uh qualified STS are on
safety critical positions uh turning to
key area of medical um the committee
will be aware that the club has had some
issues with its medical supplier in
previous years uh I'm happy to announce
that last year we moved to a different
medical provider and we now contracted
with a company called Cipher medical who
have a a well established CV across the
country and in fact the um the medical
provider for the Football Association
whenever England play uh within the the
UK um we've established a medical
Advisory Group one of the few premises
in the country to do so uh and we sit
under an independent chair for that
process and that gets right and down
into the detail of what types of beds we
have in the first aid room etc etc we
also o had um a self initiated no notice
inspection carried out by um an esteemed
professional in the in the area which
gave very positive feedback in a number
of areas that we can improve upon uh
We've also submitted last year an
upgraded medical plan for the operations
manual uh and we will ensure that the do
manual contains the upgraded upgraded
version for 2024 it's it's an area that
we've made significant positive progress
in um so overall there's other areas I
could talk about but don't want to take
up too much of the committee's time um
in summary uh as is well known that
there has been some challenges for the
Cricket Club since
2021 however last year we made
significant progress um despite one or
two little hiccups and I'm happy to
report to the committee that going back
to where it started is that the
investment that we've put into our staff
in in achieving their level four and
their level three qualifications should
hopefully underline the commitment that
the Cricket Club has made to improving
safety at the venue happy to take any
questions
thank you any of my colleagues having
no I
have should note that by now sorry about
that um a very general question here you
pointed out to us that the short notice
T20 called
a um was not only short notice it
happened during what the BBC call the
Festival of sport in the north of
England um do the powers that be in
Lords or wherever they reside these days
appreciate that that sort of problem is
it might arise if they simply present
you with a quarterfinal to be p played
at very short notice and clearly they
didn't consider any of the implications
of what else was going on from heading
the through to
ad thank you for your question I think
the answer is no um and I think um In
fairness to Lords is trying to manage
the calendars across the entire country
of so many U moving different parts
would prove almost impossible as I said
there was rugby league there was horse
racing I believe there was something
happened in Manchester United as well
and there was headingly happening um I
think the lesson we learn from that is
that uh is two things is one is to widen
the number of agencies that were
contracted with that we utilize which we
have done uh and then secondly as we
have learned is to to check what we're
being told is actually accurate and true
we were made certain promises and we
were let down the council um un
established that that we had uh had that
shortfall so that's why we've gone into
such detailed measures that we do for
checking and registration and as I said
we now no longer will accept staff who
are working towards a qualification from
an agency we'll only accept staff who
are qualif ified the The Wider sector
challenges of of Steward and bu agencies
is something that they need to address
in terms of making sure that people have
completed their
qualification um there is quite a lot of
contact time when somebody starts on a
level two
qualification um but his the history in
in the business has been that nobody
ever caught nobody ever completed it
because it was never really checked the
fact that Council colleagues do check it
mean that we're now more focused on
ensuring that they
deliver as qualified um qualified
stewards so um as I said Lords will do
what Lords do we just have to react
better um and said we've learned some
some lessons fairly quickly last
year thank you and good
luck thank you and just just as a
general comment I I'm aware of uh the
events of last year regarding what we
just discussed I sit on the licensing
committee unfortunately wasn't available
at the time it came through but it's
very good to see the willingness um of
working with officers in the council in
ensuring the safety of people that visit
your your ground is T amount to us and
it's obvious that it's tantamount to you
too so thank you for that agenda item
number four uh the
cons excuse me
so since 2020 say there's been a number
of um safety Advisory Group meetings
take place in relation to L Cricket Club
um don't particularly intend to go
through the all in detail the details
are contained in in the pack um in front
just just kind of give a bit of a an
overview um yeah in 2020 um me sag took
place just to to to allow the fixtures
to take place behind Clos doors for
international fixtures in 2021 safety
advisor group meetings took place in
relation to the club all being allowed
to admit Spectators back into ground um
there was an issue that was identified
in 2021 in relation to um Steward
qualifications um and there's a lot of
work that took place between the the
club and and the council to ensure that
all the required Works were done to to
resolve that and which meant by the um
the the international fixture on the
19th of July um the club was able to
have full has to within the
ground 2022 again a number of fixtures
took place U safety advisor groups took
place um some of the difference this
time that also covered um planning for
the concerts as well um in in that year
there was there was four concerts that
took
place just in relation to the concert
planning um one thing just kind of
explain a bit is at the end of the um
the the the planning process the the
council
he's in the position to kind of issue an
agreement in principle for the special
safety certificate to be issued and the
reason why an agreement in principle is
given and not the actual safety
certificate is because we need all the
relevant structural sign offs and
everything once the event has been built
so that's why generally special safety
certificates are issued quite close to
to Gates opening when all those safety
checks have been carried
out um again similar events took place
in in in 2023 as well um planning for um
spectator um Cricket fixtures and and
concerts at Lang count Cricket Club
um a lot of the detail kind of
containing the report has already been
covered by by Steve so there's not
really um much need for me to go through
that um but if there's any questions and
obviously I'm happy to take some on that
um I think just one thing just to kind
of expand on something Steve had said is
in relation to the ashes fixture on the
the first day inspection and also we we
were there we checked the the checking
process and how all that worked so
although stewards were found in saf
critical R without the necessary
qualifications as part of verifying that
signing process what we did know is that
there was suitable number of Steward
available who had the relevant
qualifications um and so the club were
very quickly able to sort out
redeployments um which one we did checks
again that afternoon um we were
satisfied that that had had all been
done the the no notice suspection the
next day confirmed that the procedures
put in in the afternoon on on day one
was still being
implemented there's probably not really
much else for me to to say unless
anybody's got any
questions
colleagues
um yeah so I guess it's one for both s
um thank you for that kind of
reassurance there were the required
number of um qualified assur in location
kind of um sound as if it was almost
kind of a processing issue um if they
were there were the required in the
location how did it come about that um
they weren't in the correct
position so after observing the um the
checking process and and watching the
briefings we then after shers have been
employed we went around the various STS
questioning stewards on the
qualifications and everything because of
the RIS band system that I've been put
in place it was quite easy to identify
quite quickly that St um kind of what
stewards were there what level of
training qualification they have and
it's by that process of going around of
of asking in quite a few of the stands
what qualifications everybody's got
looking at the wristbands we picked up
that so then we didn't cover all of the
stands as part of that check we'd kind
of got to the point where I thought
right we need to report this through to
to to to Steven Stadium control which we
did and then when we did the um the kind
of the pull-up visit in the afternoon
after the redeployments had taken place
we then we rechecked some of the areas
where we' found issues but then we all
went to stand where we hadn't been to to
make sure that you know they they'd just
not been moved into a different area um
so to speak you know so we're to verify
that actually yes everybody on position
that we spoke to had the relevant
qualifications
required and sorry so move forward you
know if you had the required number
there on that occasion they were in the
correct position how are we ensuring
that that error won't happen again what
what plan what have been put in place
yeah I mean it may be one for for for
the club to answer I think just from our
side um kind of as part of that we've
had quite a lot of discussions with the
club um kind of prior to the emergency
safety advisory meeting taking place as
well we did have by a few kind of
informal meetings to discuss all the
procedures so you know the club were
able to put over to was like the
procedures were there so I think I'll
probably hand over to Steve at this
point on on the
rest yeah thank you so um it involved um
four stward had all travel to the venue
in the same car who then said that they
were all qualified to the the stand
manager uh who didn't check that they
had the wristband so that was the
process issue which then was identified
and and as as the council colleagues
have said we had enough qualified staff
we just needed to move them around how
we've addressed that is there's now a
registration form for the stand manager
so the stand manager now has to check
the RIS band uh check the name and also
uh the jacket or tabard number that the
steward has been issued with and then
there's a series of questions in the
registration form to ensure they've been
adequately briefed uh and then that's
quality assured by the head stewards who
actually checks the forms Etc which are
then again documented so we've got
double documentation around that so
that's how we've we've addressed the
issue as you heard me allude to there in
terms of we're putting um at least seven
of our staff through a supervisor course
this year and the ultimate uh goal is to
have our own stand managers so at the
minute we have to um give that position
to agency staff and I'd much rather have
our own staff doing that so then we're
absolutely sure that they're doing the
registration process with with the
greatest level of diligence hopefully
that'll explain in some detail answer
your question
counselor uh yeah thank you and um yeah
reassuring to here that you're training
up your staff more and bringing more in
house thank
Youk you much thank you very much from
from again from our point of you the
work the advisor group does is is
extremely important in providing what we
do for the attendees so thank you for
that and uh fact again that errors were
made errors were pointed out and we're
aware there has been some press over it
but we deal with it in a proper way with
um communication and consult
consultation to get to the right area
and it's good to see that this is
happening okay thank you very much on to
agenda item number five which is over to
Manchester United Representatives if
you'd like
to do the
same thank you chair thank you for the
opportunity to present this evening uh
the committee have had the full report
through so my intention as per our
colleagues from LS will be to do a
summation and then obviously feel any
questions that you may have so the
review submitted runs from the period of
6th of July 22 to the 19th of June
relating to the 2223 season it's safe to
say it was an extremely challenging
season which included the mid-season
break to accommodate the World Cup and
guitar and we had a number of fixtures
across various competitions which led to
a high number of fixtures 43 in fact
which consisted of 19 Premier League
women's Super League games we had the
UEFA Europa League fixtures we also had
the rugby Super League final the Rugby
League World Cup double header with both
games played uh soccer raid and also uh
we're very proud to host the England
women's Euro Opening match at the
stadium but it did lead to a very very
busy season for the club from a Safety
Management point of view as we've said a
result of the break and the fixture
calendar the the season was very
congested both pre and postor cup not
aided by the fact that we seem to
progress to every home draw we could do
for the season so it it's very diff very
busy for us and a lot of planning and a
lot of uh assistance from tnbc and our
multi- agency partners so throughout the
season we continued with digital
ticketing in the home areas and also
moving forward we're looking at rolling
that out to the away fans as well that's
gone very well during the the season in
question the stadium continued to be
cashless following the covid pandemic
through the season season and now that's
fully embedded in all our working uh
practices we had a successful trial of
safe standing area during the previous
season uh so we were licensed for for
this season in relation to 2,150
positions that were within the stadium
and also during the break for the World
Cup we further expanded our safe
standing to areas of the away section
increasing it by 1800 which has gone
very
well the barrier seating has been
successful and in addition to domestic
fixtures uer also tried safe standing
areas as part of their competition which
led to us being uh visited by a safe
standing Observer on behalf of UEFA and
due to the success of that trial it's
continued uh from that
point for this season we also saw the
introduction of Premier League Safety
and Security delegates who attend each
home fixture and in addition to any
other audit that we we have we now have
a report submitted following every
Premier League fixture which gives
feedback back on the Safety and Security
operation and management and the
effectiveness of that which is available
to colleagues in the council to
view for the highrisk fixtures during
the season we continued the use of
erecting steel fencing and screening
outside the away away turn Styles and
also of the option of erecting netting
in front of the AA sporters which was
deemed as a step forward in relation to
ensuring the safe access and eress of
the fans for the fixtures as mentioned
in the report we did see uh protest
activi due to anti honor sentiment which
started in Earnest at the Brighton
fixture continued through the next two
Premier League fixtures against
Liverpool and Arsenal with the largest
activity being seen at the Liverpool
fixture during these protests there were
issues of disorder there were issues of
parate Technic activation but we worked
closely with our colleagues within the
police and also liaz and with Trafford
Council in relation to ensuring that we
had sufficient policies procedures and
effective mechanisms to manage any
protest that took place within our
footprint in relation to policing we
retain the gold silver bronze command
structure and we ensure that we have a
lead planner who attends all the silver
meetings and we also have hot debriefs
with the police following every event to
ensure that we capture anything that we
need to incre uh improve on going
forward in relation to security the
major project that was completed during
this time was the hvm bads which has
assisted in our outer per
for hvm attacks and also it's important
to note that this season saw the return
of full body screening for our
supporters at the stadium following the
restrictions that have been in place
during covid so we are now back to preco
conditions in relation to searching and
security
screening we continue to ensure all our
staff undergo the uh counterterrorism
awareness courses and manat training to
make sure that our staff are as well
prepared as they can be for any
eventuality and the stadium control
control room continues to operate on a
24/7 basis with staff that are
skillfully trained to detect identify
and react to any ongoing Safety and
Security issues
247 in relation to our governance as
mentioned we work closely with GMP and
colleagues from the council and we
ensure that we uh host any inspections
either planned or ad hoc and we have had
visits from the S committee members on
several occasions during the season with
no major issues
identified medically uh we've reviewed
the medical team and the medical plan
throughout the season and is still
working extremely well under the
direction of our lead doctor that
medical plan has been reviewed
postseason and it improved going forward
just to build on all the good work that
we've done one of the major improvements
on the medical plan during this season
that falls within the report was the
introduction of the public access trauma
kits throughout the stadium which fell
out the recommendations from the
Manchester Arena attack and that along
with that was a a period of education
for staff as well in relation to
treatment of casualties and what those
packs are
for in relation to the wider operation
the safeguarding team continued to work
at UH Manchester United and the
operation During the period of this
report saw a recruitment period where we
recruited and further increased our pool
of safeguarding professionals to ensure
that the operation is in place on a
match day and continues to to lead the
way in relation to safeguard operations
at sporting
stadum during the season we see receive
a number of complaints but all
complaints are properly recorded and
dealt with in relation to our
sanctioning policy and in addition to
that we continue to use the virtual
Stuart texting system which runs on
Match days for anonymous reporting of
any issues that supporters may see whil
they're at at the stadium that sh
concludes the summation of the report
but I'm happy to feel any questions that
you may have on its content thank you
very much colleagues do we have any
questions thank you very much um we'll
move on to the subcomittee report on the
council um as we've done previously I
don't intend to go back fully um to 2020
which is what the report covers um I
will start um just summarizing the
report from um September 2022 so we hold
um approximately three safety Advisory
Group meetings each year for my
Manchester United um and that's due
mainly to the number of fixtures and we
try and tackle it like a three month
period let's have a look at that um the
safety Advisory Group um comprises of
the police um Northwest embling service
fire service tfgm so everybody is on is
on that meeting um the September 2022 W
focused on looking at um safe standing
um and I think the introduction of more
uh rail seating and safe standing areas
within the stadium um we undertook a
number of match day visits to the
stadium to check on um compliance with
persistent standing and other um and
other such things um the community
safety team at Trafford have also been
doing some work in relation to um tion
on the streets um around on a match day
and I think some work's been carried out
um in conjunction with Manchester United
provide toilet facilities um to try and
reduce um the nuisance which is caused
by that um in July 2023 we had um an
update of what had happened the season
just gone which is what John's just
covered now and then we saw um a a look
forward to this season which showed um
an increased number of fixtures likely
to be held at the stadium to include
women's Super League fixtures and um um
some Academy games as well um we' were
provided with updates on stewarding
recruitment Audits and
retention um as well as some changes
which have been made to Medical
provision within the stadium on a match
day
um the we have carried out audits on the
physical factors of safety at the
stadium as well as safety factors and
we're still working with the club to
sort of bring those to a conclusion for
during this season
um and that's about it
really I think any questions
from um I just got a couple of things i'
like just like to uh out
[Music]
the I'm going a little back to 2021
where the ambulance service were
concerned somewhat with the radios in
some part of the stadium which I'm sure
with the fabric of the
stadium can cause a problem uh I wonder
if that has been
resolved we just mention we also mag
process this was raised in the mag
process so it was looked at at the time
it was examined at the time we worked
with nwas in relation to putting
effective working practices in to make
sure that the radio system wasn't
compromised on a match day for the
operational efficiency we have worked
with nwas and motor roler since then
there are still um two spots within the
stadium that are affected uh but at this
present moment in time there's no
long-term solution however there is a
separate sag in the next couple of weeks
in relation to any potential issues that
that may cause and that to assure the
SAG that we have sufficient workarounds
in
place thank thank you for that but
obviously with the tragic events
recently uh at the Bolton game it's
quite an important thing and having been
on the tour of your security the box and
in know in a steward briefing I know
that is for the club as well um just
also for the environment um sorry I just
come in there from just to add to the
work that we've done with most of all
around the club themselves pretty much
we share all the intelligence with our
staff and all the medical providers that
are there so just back up the work
that's been done there's been
installation of additional Hardware in
the control room which is a Bas set
that's hardwired with an additional a
and improves the communications so
although we do still experience some
problems they have improved drastic
theal concern yeah that's that's great
and like I said in leading the fabric of
the stadium isn't conducive to radio
communications and nothing you can do
about that particularly but obviously
you can um moving forward on the
environmental um all again in the
reports uh the additional toilet
facilities have been added there was a
mention of allgates to be installed
around the the coell area and have value
progressed or is that become something
that's not another Council W Council
colleagues were looking at
it yeah we received feedback from uh
local counselors we meet with the local
counselors um quarterly and we received
feedback from residents that were
experienc in some nuisance on mat day so
in collaboration uh we looked at it
assess the problem work with the police
with local Authority your community
safety team and we funded the
installation of SM gates in close
proximity to the stadium and that's seen
a total sociation of complaints in
addition we've put in place additional
temporary toilets on our footprint in
around match day because we recognize
there's an absence of any public toilets
in the public realm in around Stadium
thank you thank you uh I'm aware of the
the quot meeting you have and and the
very well received by the councilors
um
sorry I just going to confirm
that that the um been that very close
collaborative
work and uh and certainly the uh
manchest
police been very mindful of this issue
um so Cas of I think joint working
between the club the council in terms of
our community safety responsibilities
and also GMP alongside the physical work
and that does
as again from from conversations with
Ward colleagues and since I join the
council I'm aware that there's a lot
title Bond between the council and
yourselves and the ward counselors and
and know is
appreciated and I
think that's that's me with cover the
stewards uh yeah that's me thank you
very much indeed thank you we'll move on
to the final agenda item which is if
there's any other business I'm not aware
of
any no okay thank you very much for your
attendance I'll call the meeting to a
close thank you
yes